If my oncologist is insisting on chemotherapy and seems to go against everything, I suggest
what should I do?
Well, I would find a different oncologist, you know, it's still a free world and we still
live in a free health, free world healthcare system.
I mean, you don't have to stay with who you were initially assigned, assigned.
So you can even in their old system, let's say you were going to Minnesota oncology or
you're going to Mayo and you don't like your oncologist, you know, just feel like nothing
is your suggestions are not being heard, your desires are not being heard.
You feel like they just don't really care or you feel like they just, you know, are pushing
their agenda, whatever it is, you know, if you don't like me, you don't have to stay with
me, you don't like your oncologist, go to someone else, there's nothing wrong with
that.
You don't, you're not here to please, some people are such people pleasers, you're afraid
you're going to hurt somebody's feelings and then you put your life at risk.
So don't be foolish, you know, there's lots of oncologists that will take you, especially
if you go to them and say, hey, I was at Mayo and they were just pushing their agenda,
they really want to find somebody that I can work with.
The next person you talk to will probably be somebody with, I would never do that.
Oh, no, we can work with you, even though they might have done that to somebody else, you
know, two visits before that.
So just raise your concerns, you know, and, you know, again, like anything, I don't think
you should be dogmatically positioned either way, I think the best thing is to with a lot
of prayer and supplication, bring your request made known to God and He will direct your
paths and He will give you peace that passes all understanding.
If you don't have peace about doing a certain therapy that you shouldn't do that therapy, above
all things, you want to be obedient to what God is leading you to do, not doing something
to please someone else or doing something to, to a piece of system, and that includes
not just your, your oncologist includes family members, you have to stand up for what God
is telling you to do.
Years ago, I had a patient that came to me, a pancreatic cancer, late stage, just diagnosed.
He was doing really well with alternative therapy, about just about a month into care, that's
who we saw a lot, we had, did a lot of therapies in the office at the time, he was coming in
every day to do the therapies, he was looking better, his blood work was looking better, and
his son was just very upset that he was not doing chemotherapy, it was just, it was just
distraught, that he was not going to do, his dad was not going to do chemotherapy, he thought
his dad was going to die, if he didn't do chemotherapy, he was just literally having panic attacks.
And that's what caused the dad to cave, it said, I'm going to go, I just don't think I should
do this, but I'm going to go ahead and do it.
Because I don't just really care, obviously for my son, he did chemotherapy, he died in
just a couple weeks, I'm convinced of the chemotherapy, he wasn't, his cancer was not progressing,
the chemotherapy for pancreatic cancer is very severe, and that's one of the main reasons
I believe that pancreatic cancer patients tend not to survive, do not do things just because
someone else is pressuring you to do that, no matter if somebody you love or somebody
you don't know, it's, you do things in anything in life, whether it's making a decision about
your health care or making a decision about your job, you should be doing things because you're
consulting by the power of the Holy Spirit, your Heavenly Father, and being obedient to God
is foremost in having a relationship with God.
My children will hear my voice, it says, Jesus said, and we need to be listening to it in
much prayer in all our big life decisions.
We don't need to spiritualize, you know, whether we should buy butter or the store or something
else, but we make it big life decisions.
These are the things that we are to take to the Lord, and he desires for us to depend on
him for those things.